this episode of the Y files is brought
to you by
hu on April 7th 2016 the team running
NASA's New Horizons Mission were waiting
nervously the spacecraft was about to
enter the outermost reaches of our solar
system they had aimed toward Pluto which
lives in a region of the solar system
called the Kyper belt just before
arriving at the dwarf planet the team
noticed an object nearby and it was
acting very strange this object whatever
it was was spinning fast faster than
everything else around it too fast
artificially fast New Horizons changed
course to do a flyby they wanted a
better look at this bizarre behavior but
as the spacecraft approached the object
all Communications went down NASA wasn't
able to see or hear anything something
or someone was blocking the signal
whoever it was did not want NASA to know
they were there and that they've been
watching us for a very long
time
[Music]
yeah human perfect look I need your help
no Hi how are you oh I'm sorry how rude
of me Hi how are you are you having a
good day everything good with you well
I'm having a pretty good day about to
have some lunch how about you I told you
I need your help this is an emergency
okay what's going on well this month is
my turn to host my pean knole group
host where your house uh before we start
playing the ladies and I have a little
uh prep knuckle pot like dinner and
Doris is going to bring her famous tuna
noodle cancero tuna can you believe it
she does it just to spite me because I
always beat her at P gal wait I I I
thought you only play peanuckle ah we do
a ho casino night it ain't legal but
it's a lot of fun okay I get it I want
to eat what do you want I got to make
something delicious that will blow her
stupid casserole out of the
water get it one more pun and I'm
hanging up okay okay sorry sorry uh look
can you help me out okay when is the
party in 5 minutes 5 minutes I was
cleaning the house watching the YouTubes
and I got sucked into this camel
grooming Channel and I lost track of
time and by the way don't tell Gertie I
was watching that okay she gets jealous
okay well I have something delicious
nutritious you can make fast and it's
totally plant-based
plantbased perfect I'll show that dor we
don't need to add fish to a meal to make
it amazing well look in the pantry
there's another bag of hu hot and savory
you'll thank me later oh is this today
sponsor as a matter of fact it is fuel
hot and savory makes Nutrition a whole
lot easier it's a balanced plant-based
meal with 27 vitamins and minerals it's
high in protein low in sugar and salt
and an easy source of fiber I'm just
getting ready to eat the Cajun pasta it
tastes great and it's an easy affordable
way to have a quick delicious meal oh
Cajun pasta is perfect it'll be my pre
peanuckle potluck pasta Perfection well
great now go to my.u.com theey files
October and get your own with your first
order you get free shipping a free hu
t-shirt and a get started guide that's
my.u.com theey files October yep great
I'll do it as soon as
a welcome ladies the tables are set up
on the Leni and the Mari B starts in 15
uh don't rush home these ladies they
like the party did you say
[Music]
Mariachi the Kyper belt is a
donut-shaped region of space way out on
the far end of the solar system and it
is a huge region of space its inner Edge
begins at the orbit of Neptune at about
30 AU from the Sun now one Au or
astronomical unit is the distance from
the Earth to the Sun so the inner edge
of the Kyper belt is about 2.8 billion
miles from the Sun then it extends for
about another 4 and2 billion miles now
beyond the Kyper belt is a structure
called the or cloud and that place is
way farther much bigger and really
strange we'll cover the or cloud in
another episode now the existence of the
Kyper belt was first hypothesized in
1943 by Irish astronomer Kenneth
Edgeworth he felt there was a reservoir
of comets and asteroids residing in the
solar system beyond the planets
Edgeworth was right and the Kyper belt
was finally visually confirmed in 1992
David JT and grad student Jane Lou
discovered the first Kyper built objects
were kbos now kbos are the various
comets dwarf planets asteroids and other
icy bodies that make up the Kyper belt
jitt and Lou named their Discovery as a
tribute to Gerard Kyper who's considered
to be the father of planetary science
before he proposed the concept of the
Kyper belt in 1951 he'd already
discovered the moons of Neptune you did
he look at
Uranus we going to do this every time
what I just want to know if this
scientist was interested in Uranus he
was he's the one who discovered its
moons yeah if you look close enough
you'll see plenty of stuff around Uranus
okay hey ladies if a man is willing to
give you the moon and the stars the
least you could do is give him Uranus
that's
[Music]
enough we've been aware of the Kyper
belt for a long time but didn't realize
it Pluto is actually a kbo and one of
the largest of the dwarf planets at 1500
Mi it even has its own moons which is
probably why astronomers called it a
planet for so long in the more than 30
years since its Discovery the Kyper belt
is still a
mystery the Kyper belt is truly a
frontier in space it's a place we're
still just beginning to explore and our
understanding is still evolving along
with countless comets and asteroids the
Kyper belt is home to at least seven
dwarf planets most of which are roughly
600 to 900 mi in diameter ays discovered
in 2005 is the most massive object found
so far and new kbos are discovered all
the time now most of the objects found
in the Kyper belt are easy to explain
they're easy to identify and they're
easy to track but there are things in
the Kyper belt that don't act like
science says they should they're
unpredictable they're unnatural and some
would say they seem almost intentional
these Kyper belt objects challenge our
understanding of the solar system and
whether we are the only ones
here on May 12th 1994 Michael Irwin and
Anna jitk were working late yeah and
shitov Anna jitk what I
say they were the on duty astronomers at
the rod deos machacho observatory in the
Canary Islands it was a quiet night like
any other night and then they spotted
something it glowed and then dimmed it
glowed and then dimmed this was
different than any other object around
it it glowed and dimmed in a regular
rhythm every 5 and a half hours which by
space standards is fast insanely fast
too
fast so fast the centrifugal force
should rip a regular kbo apart most
Kyper built objects are bits of dust and
Ice they shatter like glass Anna and
Michael had never seen anything like
this according to science this object
shouldn't even exist this gave the
astronomers an ominous feeling current
technology didn't allow them to get a
good enough look to fully identify it so
they named it after the Welsh god of the
underworld atow 23 years later
technology caught up we were finally
able to get close enough for a
look in April 2016 NASA's New Horizons
Mission reached the Kyper belt next stop
down it was on the way to Pluto the
perfect flyby opportunity to answer a
decades old question what the heck is
this crazy spitting object at the end of
the solar
system but just as new Horizons moved in
for the
closeup things went dark nothing
worked there had been what's called a
CPU safing event that put New Horizons
into safe mode safe mode shuts down all
essential systems and is triggered
automatically when the spacecraft
detects something unusual but the team
was stumped after a few hours of The
Craft running in safe mode one NASA
engineer approached his supervisor ER
with a terrifying idea the engineer
looked around as if to reveal a secret
and then quietly said it seems like
someone is jamming the signal as if they
were aware of our presence and didn't
want us to see what they were doing and
the way ad down spun that insanely Fast
5 and 1/2 hour rotation no one had
figured that out yet in over 20 years
since first seeing it and those who
tried to understand the spin agreed ad's
movements seemed artificial it was cre
creating its own gravity within the
interior of the
object now the concept of spin gravity
wasn't new to NASA NASA started
experimenting with artificial gravity in
the 1960s experts have developed ideas
for space stations filled with small
towns and farms and Parks the space
station could be designed as a giant
spinning cylinder each of these
structures could rotate to create
artificial gravity along the inner
surface we've seen this concept in
science fiction over and over again but
science fiction is about as far as these
ideas have gotten test results on
artificial gravity are always the same
humans are not well suited to it when
exposed to artificial gravity we're
subjected to what's known as coriolis
Force deviation this causes motions
going in a straight line to bend often
quite a lot coriolis causes motion
sickness and all sorts of other
dysfunctions humans living in artificial
gravity do not do well basically we puke
and die doesn't take a rocket scientist
to know that vomit on a space station is
a problem but a down was spinning in a
way that seemed like someone was
controlling it and if there is someone
controlling the object they don't want
to be seen and of all the places in the
solar system the Kyper belt is the best
place to hide the Kyper belt is 30 to 50
times farther away from the Sun than we
are at that distance things get really
dark also the Kyper belt is littered
with random oddly shaped objects it
wouldn't be hard to hide amongst the
mess these were the kinds of questions
being asked when New Horizons went dark
now after a while the spacecraft drifted
away from it around suddenly New
Horizons came back to life booted up and
the journey into the Kyper belt
continued as planned but what just
happened and how did it happen but
before these questions could be answered
someone realized Adam wasn't alone in
its odd behavior New Horizons was
surrounded by kbos acting strangely it
was like something was bending the laws
of physics and the deeper New Horizons
moved into the darkness the more they
realized they weren't
alone according to the Nemesis Theory we
live in a two star or binary solar
system our son the only star we can see
has a companion star a brown dwarf
residing deep in the Kyper belt
Brown dwarfs are actually called failed
Stars they're huge objects about 80
times the size of Jupiter but they don't
have enough Mass to ignite their
hydrogen cores so they don't burn they
don't shine but in the depths of the
Kyper belt a brown dwarf would be
invisible this object is known as Planet
X or planet
9u right some people think Planet X is
Nibiru home of the Anunnaki yeah still
waiting on that anunaki episode Chief
and I'm working on
it Planet X lies well beyond Pluto
extremely far away but this enormous
object is still close enough to
influence the orbits of the outer
planets in our solar system and
everything else in the Kyper belt now it
sounds like science fiction but it's not
NASA has been actively searching for
Planet X for decades if it's out there
it would explain why some Kyper Bel
objects act so weird but Planet X
doesn't explain all kbos along with ar
there are a few kbos that make no sense
at all meet kbo 2008 KV 42 a comet
within the Kyper belt KV 42 is nicknamed
Dr after Dracula as vampires have the
ability to walk on walls H so this Comet
walks on walls sort of yeah everything
in the solar system moves around the Sun
in the same direction this is called
prograde orbit and if you look at the
orbits of all the objects from the side
they're basically on the same flat plane
this is called the plane of the ecliptic
so you remember how Dracula can walk on
walls that's what Dr is doing with its
orbit Dr moves in total retrograde in
the opposite direction of everything
else and it ignores the plane of the
ecliptic it's just out there doing its
own thing and Dr ain't small this comet
is 30 m across if it hit Earth it would
cause an extinction level event actually
Dr could destroy the Earth entirely now
thankfully dr's orbit is about twice as
far as Neptune but we're still keeping
an eye on it now new photos of the outer
bands of the Kyper belt are coming out
all the time thanks to the James web
Space Telescope but what we're told and
what we're shown is incredibly
controlled on this channel we've proven
that NASA Alters images before releasing
them to the public we've talked about
plenty of NASA's bizarre comments and
outright lies then every so often we're
teased with headlines about potentially
science changing discoveries bizarre
object 10 million times brighter than
the sun defies physics NASA says NASA's
James web Space Telescope may have found
early galaxies that shouldn't be there
web telescope spots strange objects in
the Orion Nebula they aren't planets or
stars and according to the astronomers
who found them they shouldn't exist
strange circles seen in space baffles
scientists even though these are all
legitimate news reports covering a
official NASA press releases they
meaningless clickbait when the Press
asks for specific data on their
investigations NASA spits out overly
scientific jargon none of it means
anything but despite all these efforts
to suppress information there are a few
brave people coming forward with very
interesting new information these people
know a lot about the Kyper belt how do
they know so much well because they were
there
Rebecca Rose was only 4 years old the
first time it happened she woke up from
a deep sleep with a sense she wasn't
alone she tried to move to cry out she
couldn't she was paralyzed several
strangers were in her bedroom they
hovered silently over her bed but she
couldn't make out their faces then there
was a flash of blinding bright light and
the rush of cold
air for a brief moment Rebecca felt
weightless when her eyes adjusted she
realized she wasn't in her room anymore
she tried to move but she was still
paralyzed and now strapped to a metal
table the room was sterile and metallic
with strange equipment hanging on the
walls the air was warm humid and thick
with a pungent medicinal smell she
spotted a figure in the corner one of
the strangers the tall one she called
him though his mouth didn't move she
heard him say you are in no danger we
just want you to play Rebecca was
confused then the stranger gestured to a
small table on the other side of the
room there were books puzzles and all
kinds of games some games tested logic
some tested math some tested visual
comprehension and memory for what felt
like hours Rebecca solved what puzzle
she could then the stranger approached
smiled at her and everything once again
went
[Music]
white
Rebecca opened her eyes and saw she was
back in bed and just in time for school
as far as she knew she was unharmed
except for a persistent nose bleed
Rebecca went to school like any other
day the memories of her experience faded
quickly like when you lose the details
of a dream so by the time Rebecca was
being tucked into bed that night she
barely remembered anything at all she
peacefully drifted off to sleep but soon
she'd realize this was only the
beginning The Strangers kept coming back
night after night and Rebecca would take
tests and solve puzzles night after
night as these experiences became more
routine and as she got older Rebecca was
able to learn more about what was
happening to her first her playroom or
whatever you'd call it is on a base on
the Moon from her window she could see a
sprawling complex of buildings built
into the familiar white cratered
landscape and eventually Rebecca
realized the strangers weren't human she
was being abducted by aliens aliens of
many different races she saw mantids who
resembled large praying mantises she
mostly saw aliens that we would call
Grays during one of her sessions the
Grays activated Rebecca's psychic
abilities all humans have this gift but
very few of us have access to it the
puzzle and tests Rebecca had been taking
over the years were actually a psychic
training program to teach Rebecca how to
access and control her psychic abilities
once Rebecca became skilled in telepathy
she was forced to telepathically
interface with beings who were being
held captive on the
base some of the beings looked human
others didn't but she was able to feel
that they were all sensient and aware of
what was happening to them and she could
sense they were all terrified through
the telepathic interface Rebecca
extracted DNA samples for what purpose
she didn't know and she didn't
ask after 4 years of intense training
Rebecca was summoned to a meeting she
saw mants and Grays but she also saw men
dressed in military uniforms they sat
her down and said Rebecca your training
is over you're ready Rebecca asked ready
for what they finally told her why she'd
been visiting the moon base for the last
4 years and why she was taken from her
family why she had to interface with
alien species and why she was taught to
develop her psychic powers they said
Rebecca you're joining the dark
[Music]
Fleet after her training 9-year-old
Rebecca Rose was taken from her home for
the last time she was brought to the
Great Lakes Naval Station and put
through trauma-based mind control
programming this was done using
techniques perfected in the cia's MK
Ultra project next she's strapped to a
seat and sent through a jump gate jump
gates are portals that can transport
people and objects across huge distances
instantly Rebecca would now begin her
20year Mission and so she
[Music]
jumped
for the next few years Rebecca spent
most of her time on Air Patrol the Mars
Defense Force used retrofitted
helicopters to protect the area around
the dark Fleet base on Mars protect the
base from what indigenous Martian life
like the mantids and reptilians lizard
martians yep primary mission was to
protect the base but if she could
capture an alien to acquire its
technology that would be even better oh
it's very hard to snatch a lizard
Martian get crafty well that may be true
but Rebecca was given cybernetic
enhancements to turn her into a super
soldier enhancements focused on
optimizing physiology enhancing psychic
abilities increasing durability and
combat Effectiveness she also had
Advanced armor and weapon systems
directly integrated with her body and
her cybernetic technology this is one
cuffed R she was because of her
cybernetic systems and enhanced
abilities Rebecca was an extreme
valuable asset to the Mars Defense Force
maybe too valuable wait wait wait what
do you mean toward the end of her
20-year tour Rebecca was sold to the
draconians not the
[Music]
Draco beyond the Kyper belt is Planet X
the brown dwarf and Planet X is ruled by
the
draconians the draconians are a powerful
reptilian species they're the most
ancient race in the solar system they
control large bases and ships throughout
and Beyond the kyber belt and the
draconians are to be feared first of all
they're intimidating to look at most
Draco are over 20 ft tall with wings
they have the ability to paraliz people
just by looking at them here's how
another Soldier described one without
any warning whatsoever we were all
paralyzed no one could even talk I was
instantly nauseated wanting to both
throw up and crack all at once it felt
very violating what was unfolding I
didn't get any of it and even more
disturbing it was all mental I Heard a
Voice inside of my head a very loud deep
voice frightening as hell up until that
point all of my telepathic encounters
were of a normal exchange felt much like
the volume and intensity of my own
thoughts this was anything but but the
biggest reason to fear the Draco is
technology they've mastered Advanced
holographic technology psychic
manipulation and portal Tech far beyond
anything humans have so Rebecca was sold
to the Draco as part of a diplomatic
trade package basically take our best
soldiers and please don't kill us
draconians use their advanced technology
and psychic powers to dominate worlds
through fear and force they had built an
Empire as slave Traders and Planet X is
their home world if the Draco demand a
few human soldiers is tribute you have
no choice but to comply so Rebecca was
put to work as a patrol pilot once again
but this time she was protecting a large
ship that was orbiting Planet X her time
serving the Draco was very traumatizing
she was forced to kill non-threatening
beings her life was brutal but she had
her training and she had her cybernetic
enhancements to keep her going but there
was light at the end of the tunnel for
Rebecca her 20-year commitment was about
to
end there was a roar in her ears a flash
of bright light and the familiar feeling
of weightlessness
then
silence then Rebecca heard birds outside
children playing she was back home and
not just back home on Earth she was back
in her 9-year-old body all the memories
of her last 20 years started to vanish
who who was this all a dream nope the
memories were real they were fading
because the dark fleet was wiping her
brain but in 2012 at age 40 Rebecca
suffered a freak accident and then all
the memories came rushing back but she
wasn't alone in her experience many
other people have come forward all
describing similar childhood experiences
the Abduction the training the
deployment to various bases and the
20year commitment the whistleblowers
call the program 20 and back these
children are forced into a slave likee
Warrior state they're genetically
engineered over their entire lives they
endure physical and psychological abuse
that we can't imagine and suffer in ways
that would cause most people to break
all this suffering for a 20-year space
program or a dark Fleet controlled by
the US Navy but ultimately to serve the
Galactic
Federation scientists still don't know
why the New Horizon spacecraft shut down
when it approached in the kyber belt but
the survivors of the 20 and back program
they know why humans are not allowed out
that far the human race is permitted to
travel to the edge of the kyber belt but
no farther the entire solar system May
belong to us but everything else it
belongs to the
[Music]
Draco there are many people who claim to
be Veterans of the 20 in back space
Force program it's a complex topic and
deserves its own episode so if You' like
to see that let me know but I will cover
this in more detail on the podcast so is
the 20 in backstory or the dark Fleet
true probably not almost definitely not
it's hard to know for sure where the
story started because there's a lot of
drama around it most people believe it
started with Cory good between the age
of 16 and 17 years old I was transported
to the moon and after 20 years I was age
regressed back in time and then returned
to civilian life he came on the scene
around 2010 with the story of being
recruited as a child into a secret space
program he made a big splash with the
story and gained a large following but
he admits that some of the story is real
and some is made up what does it matter
if it's real or not I'm asking you
whether it was dramatization or was it
real it's um a real part of
my dream or delusion of whatever you
want to call it I
created created all of this but which
memories are real and which are not he
doesn't know some of these memories
could be real or they could be creation
uh I'm not exactly sure
if you can't tell which memories are
real then then how are we supposed to
know if any of this is
true hey uh by the way that doesn't look
like an interview uh it's sort of an
interview he's being deposed by an
attorney oh uh-oh yeah Cory is suing
people claiming that he owns the story
about 20 and back and the secret space
program if the story is true how can you
sue people over it like I said the 20
and back is my creation is a part of my
intellectual property uh me creating it
means it came out of me and that it is
my story and it was never anywhere
before but it's possible Cory good
didn't invent the story at all Michael
ralie published a series of books called
the Mars records in the year 2000 long
before Cory good showed up and ralie
talks about child recruitment psychic
training age regression reptilians and a
lot of the same things in the 20 and
backstory and you might remember albic
from a few of our other episodes he also
talked about age regression and being
sent back in time for ad Mission as
after I jumped off the Eldridge and went
to the year 2137 well I thought you went
to the year 1983 though that was the
last to stop but Cory says the story is
his and he's very protective of his
intellectual property especially the
secret space program he even tried to
trademark that why couldn't someone else
talk about their experience in the
secret space program as long as they
don't talk about the stuff that I
created based on my
my my real IP here I and it it says I
created a lot of the stuff I created um
uh dark Fleet dark Fleet didn't exist
before I talked about it and look if you
invented the story by all means
trademarket people will come in and they
will say oh okay I was in the secret
space program too and all of these
things that Corey has talked about I was
a part of that too well guess what the
stuff that I've talked about some of it
created out of my mind but Bill Cooper
was on CNN in 1992 and he was talking
about a secret space program uh Pluto
was the uh the application of that
technology to our own secret space
program not the public space program
there are two different space programs
one is the what the public gets to see U
which is overseen by NASA and the other
one is a secret space program that
nobody gets to see which is really
overseen by um the Navy Department uh
under under specialized U uh
compartmentalized black projects so lots
of aspects of the story have been around
for a long time here's how it seems to
work every time someone new joins the 20
in back bandwagon they bring their own
favorite sci-fi story line then each
person's story evolves feeding off the
other but who knows maybe Cory good is
telling the truth you can watch his
deposition online line and decide for
yourself true or not it's a great story
TM but aside from this one area most of
what we talked about within the Kyper
belt is real kind of now the object down
is weird and I'll be grateful to never
say that word again after today now
there are plenty of videos describing
the comet and Its Behavior but nobody
has yet to explain it and even though
NASA did lose contact with New Horizons
at one point in time there's no official
record of New Horizons breaking down
while flying by Adon in 2016 NASA says
the New Horizon's mission was an overall
success so it's unclear where the story
about the total control blackout came
from there was a brief loss of
communication on July 4th 2015 10 days
before New Horizons was due to fly by
Pluto but they were down for an hour all
the other details came from a YouTube
video Never Trust what you hear in a
YouTube video oh that's for
sure
now Planet X probably is real though
NASA prefers to call it Planet 9 I
prefer to call it niru in 2017
researchers agreed that data and
computer models prove with almost 100%
certainty a large secret dark planet is
lurking in the distant solar system
although we were initially quite
skeptical that this planet could exist
we've become increasingly convinced that
it is out there for the first time in
over 150 years there is solid evidence
that the Solar System's planetary census
is
incomplete Dr is also real I don't know
if it has anything to do with the
Draconian species who allegedly control
the solar system but Dr does fly in
retrograde it's thought humans will one
day turn the Kyper belt into a gas
station a stopping off point on our way
to deep space but for now the Kyper belt
is one giant mystery now my gut tells me
there is something important important
going on up there something which
influences life here on Earth but
there's no way to know for sure until we
send spacecraft to the Kyper belt to see
for ourselves and maybe one day we'll do
that that is if the Draco say it's
okay thank you so much for hanging out
with me today my name is AJ that's
cleish govern this has been the wi files
if you had fun or learn anything do him
a favor like subscribe comment share
that stuff really really helps the
channel and like most topics we cover
here today's is recommended by you so if
there's a story you'd like to see or
learn more about go to the Wi files.com
tips now if you need more wi files in
your life because who doesn't check out
the wi files Discord there's thousands
of people on there 24/7 and there's
always something fun going on it's free
to join so check it out and there's a
lot more wi files on the podcast every
week I do deep dives into your favorite
stories so wherever you get your podcast
podc look for the wi files operation
podcast a special thanks to our patrons
who make this whole thing possible I
dedicate everything to you and I
couldn't do it without you now if you'd
like to support the channel consider
becoming a member on patreon for as
little as $3 a month you get all kinds
of perks like early access to videos
without commercials Early Access to
products like the talking Heckle fish
plushy you get two live streams a week
just for you and all kinds of other
perks another great way to support the
channel is grab something from the wifi
store I grab yourself a heck of t-shirt
and then put that on and then get one of
those Heckle fish fishable mugs and Stam
your stick your fist and jam it in there
and then drink something delicious from
it and then go and get a heck of fish
tugg and squeezy tugg and fish plushy
toy that's going to do it until next
time be safe be kind and know that you
are
[Music]
appreciated
oh oh oh
yeah I play FIA scaria 51 a secret code
inside the Bible said I
was I love my you and paranormal fun as
well as music so singing like I
should within another conspiracy theory
becomes the truth my friends and it
never
ends no it never
[Music]
ends I feel the crap cat I got stuck
inside M's hole with mkl Tru I being
only to
aware did Stanley curi fake the moon
landing alone on a film set where the
shadow people there
throughout well aliens gets Fought The
Smiling man I'm
told and his name was
cold I can't believe I'm dancing with
the
fish fish night wedn
J through the
night all I ever wanted was to just see
the truth
theat all through the
[Music]
the MTH man SIDS and the solar storm
still come to have got the the secret
City
Underground mysterious numbers stations
planet to project Stargate and where the
dark Watchers
found in a simulation don't you worry
though the black KN satellited to me so
I can't believe I'm dancing with the
fish fish on thday nights with they J
when
weap through the
night all I ever wanted was to just hear
the truth so the one bat all through the
night fish on thday night wedn J
and through the
night all I ever wanted was to just hear
the truth so the one B timeat all
through
the love to Dan good love to Dan good
love to Dan good love to
dancee loves to
dancee loves to dance on the danceall
because she is a camel when camels love
to dance when the feeling is
right in time good love Dan good love
dance
[Music]
a